the mass
of zombies
previously people didn't care if you
said epidemiology through mathematics
all they cared about was keep me healthy
and so the way you'd sell it to people
is okay let's talk about zombieism it's
the same maths of flu
it's the same maths as
chickenpox
but it spices it up a little
and so what we're going to consider are
some zombies what's a hallmark of the
zombie well they move randomly and the
zombie
does a random walk so we can't say where
a particular zombie will be at any time
but a lot of zombies we can actually
predict we use a thing called the
diffusion equation okay so we have a
population
z that's how many zombies are at a
location at a particular time the zombie
are changing over time zt means rate of
change of zombies over time that's equal
to
dz dz tells us how fast the zombies are
moving how fast they're spreading out
big dz very fast they're riding
motorbikes small dz very slow their legs
have been cut off and then we have the
laplacian of z upside down triangle very
scary piece of mathematics but it just
means random motion okay and from this
what you get is a relation between time
a first interaction and that's
proportional to how far away you are
from them space is being x here and
their rate of diffusion diesel so t and
dz are related time of first meeting is
approximately proportional to how far
away i am from the zombie x and how fast
they're dispersing dz so if i slow the
zombies down i put pits out rubble it's
a good reason for not cleaning your room
i always say so if i halve their rate of
motion
my time
doubles
half the rate of motion double my time
so if it takes 20 minutes for them to
get to me and i put a lot of things out
that will stop them it'll take 40
minutes to get to me okay that's that's
that's useful that's useful to know but
what's more useful to know
is x because time and space are related
quadratically what does that mean well
if i
double the distance between me and the
zombies because of this x squared time
is increased by full so i double my
distance
let's say 10 meters i go to 20 meters
away my time has gone from 10 minutes to
40 minutes so it's much better to run
away from a zombie than it is to try and
slow them down i won't judge you i will
be at the head of the people i know this
i've got a plan to get out of the way
i'm not trying to stop them i'm running
away so
don't worry i'll be a chicken you'll be
a chicken we'll all be a chicken that
does kind of
assume you have an infinite ability to
run away whereas if you put an obstacle
down an obstacle will be there forever
very true very true and that's a good
point and you might also trip over that
obstacle very good i mean uh the uk
isn't that big
you can keep running in fact we wouldn't
have very far to run until we hit the
the sea from from from where you're
living here brady so i'd just like to
say maybe think about moving if a zombie
apocalypse happens this is telling us
about the start of an apocalypse okay
what should we do run away but you're
quite right we now have to add in
interactions
so what can zombies and humans do when
they meet so we're gonna have zombies
meet humans zombie plus human what can
come out of their interaction we can
have the zombie kill the human so zombie
meets a human zombie survives not great
the human can kill a zombie great we've
survived we've got a good outcome and a
bad outcome but that's certainly not the
worst outcome
what's the worst outcome we get bitten
and we end up with two zombies so now
what we can do is rewrite this in terms
of our equation so now we have two
populations to keep tabs on we have the
zombies they're diffusing moving
randomly they don't know what they're
doing they're mindless and we're going
to say that because of these
interactions something can happen we can
increase the zombie population at a rate
proportional to what's happening so
let's give these three rates
this can happen at a rate a a rate b and
a rate c all it really means is
whichever's biggest is the one that's
most likely to happen if b was really
big then the zombies are ineffectual you
know they're flies you're just batting
them out away keep away go away i don't
want you if c is really big then
zombieism is very infectious you know
they saliva can pass it on very
infectious we don't want that so this is
the equation we're going to write down
from this set up here zombies are moving
randomly
and what we have is that the humans kill
the zombies so we lose some zombies at a
rate b
that's the amount that are killed by the
humans but we gain zombies at a rate c
okay that's all that happens we gain
zombies through zombification we lose
zombies because of humans killing
zombies we have to also account for the
humans so human population changing over
time i'm also going to consider the
humans are moving randomly
now generally that's not true you know
where you're going to be most of the
time
but i'm going to suggest that if the
dead start to rise you may not go to
work that day you may not go to school
you might panic
and try and escape so that's what i'm
saying here that humans are panicking
they're moving randomly not many people
have a zombie plan the fools and we have
the same idea here we put on the kinetic
so what can happen we can die at a rate
a and we die at the rate c so that's
that's the entirety of a zombie
population written down in two simple
equations simple equations
so what do they tell us well the first
thing we can do is is simplify this bit
of it so let's have a look at the human
equation this term is always negative
now i shouldn't have to tell anyone
who's seen a zombie film before or
anyone in fact but it's never beneficial
for a human to meet a zombie
yes we can kill them but it doesn't
increase our population we are assuming
that our zombie pandemic occurs over a
short time because you know we could
have added in birth rates into this but
i'm going to say that most zombie films
are around an hour and a half it takes
nine months to give birth so i'm going
to say that birth isn't really going to
affect this equation too much because of
this term being negative we are always
losing human population
don't meet a zombie
now let's look at the zombie equation to
this idea of connect reaction terms
random motion and then we put c minus
bhc now this term can either be positive
or negative what does that mean if this
is positive
c is larger than b
the zombies are infecting more people
than we're killing they're very
infectious
if b is bigger than c we are killing
more zombies than they are infecting
this is negative so this again tells us
what situation we to be able to survive
we need to kill more zombies than they
are infectious okay again this makes
sense you know all i'm doing is
converting our knowledge of any good
zombie film into mathematics but this
does tell us one more thing because
these equations are can be seen as a
fischer equation which is a type of
equation in mathematics
and that equation has a wave structure
in it
so what we'll have is our city we'll
have the zombies being green
and we'll put them here we'll put all of
our zombies in a graveyard and we're
going to say that the rest of our city
the humans are pretty well spread out
long as city if you run these equations
you will find that this spreads out like
a wave invading the blue either eating
them or turning them some of the zombies
may die but a lot more of the humans
will be converted and eaten that's also
a big problem you may want to think
about your strategies now essentially
all of the humans around you if you're
in a populated place they're just
potential zombies for you
um
think about that for a second but what
is the speed of this wave so we'll call
this v it's move this wave is is
charging through the human population at
a rate v and v
is proportional to
the square root of dz h0 and c minus b
okay some of these we've seen before
some of them we haven't dz we've seen
before that's just the spread
of the zombies
you slow the zombies down you slow the
speed down makes sense
c minus b that was this term here the
rate of zombie production minus the rate
of zombie killing this term can be
negative but it's inside a square root
that means if we make this negative this
can't happen we need to be more deadly
than the zombies are infectious if
that's possible we stop the infection
spreading now h0 we've not spoken about
this parameter yet h0 is the initial
population of the humans if you can
isolate yourself remove anyone
potentially around you great you don't
have to worry but if you're surrounded
by humans
all they are to you
are potential infections i'm not saying
you should get rid of those humans
i'm just saying what the math says brady
you may choose to interpret it however
you so wish i see i interpreted that as
i just need to move out to the country
but you're saying i need to kill the
humans no i specifically said i i did
not say that i've said you need to
isolate yourself in some way however
true however disclaimer disclaimer
this episode was supported by brilliant
makers of fantastic courses puzzles
lessons that you can do from your
computer tablet or phone i've always
been a bit partial to perfect numbers so
i've been enjoying this one everything
on brilliant is lovingly designed and
super interactive as you can plainly see
here
i've met the people at brilliant and
they're so passionate about making the
world a smarter place improving our
brains
check them out
it's brilliant.org number five you can
get started for free go and have a look
around
then if you decide to go deeper maybe
get the premium subscription well that
slash number file that's going to get
you a 20 discount that's brilliant.org
slash number file our thanks to them for
supporting this episode
and you get extra growth from it and
then you see that in the fact that the
bigger that bulge gets the bigger your
black hole gets as well one fact i know
about eyes so this is like where all the
blood is flowing into it right if you're
god and you're designing an eye you
might put all of those blood vessels
behind where it's actually receiving
light